-Making his TV debut,
performing "Back in Blood,"
from his debut mix tape,
"Shiesty Season,"
here is Pooh Shiesty
featuring Lil Durk!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Rapping ] ♪ Smurk ♪
-♪ Mm, mm, big blrrrd, huh? ♪
-♪ I don't know why he want
something back from me ♪
-[ Echoing ] ♪ Turn me up, YC ♪
♪ Yeah, I give you this
in blood ♪
[ Rapping ] ♪ Blrrrd, blrrrd,
blrrrd, I got my own fire ♪
♪ Don't need security in no ♪
♪ All that woofin' on the net,
I thought you was a ♪
♪ They ain't got nowhere to go,
we shot up everywhere they was ♪
♪ Yeah, you know who took that,
come get it back in blood ♪
♪ Blrrrd, blrrrd ♪
♪ Come get it back in blood ♪
♪ We ain't mask up, no dodger,
rich know who it ♪
♪ Extortin' just like the '80s,
want something back, get it in ♪
♪ Yeah, you know who took that
from you, come get it back in ♪
♪ If your killer ain't dead,
you shouldn't wear no R.I.P. ♪
♪ We had three hundred shots up
in the car before we picked up ♪
♪ Who ain't got goin',
go grab a glizzy, get alert ♪
♪ Shiesty G post "R.I.P."
and reason he in the dirt ♪
♪ Blrrrd, you gotta know
I go too far ♪
♪ It's two O's up
on this hundred ♪
♪ One of 'em might
stand for O'Block ♪
♪ Twenty some shots left up in
the K, fifteen still in the ♪
♪ Keep my door unlocked
and stop ♪
♪ I like gettin' on feet,
park the car ♪
♪ Hey, gettin' up close,
do him dirty, I ain't showin' ♪
♪ Eleven thousand all ones
left my right pocket in the ♪
♪ These blue faces up on me
dirty, up out the mud ♪
♪ If I took something, get it in
blood, I don't give a what we ♪
♪ Blrrrd ♪
♪ Don't need security
in no club ♪
♪ All that woofin' on the net,
I thought you was a thug ♪
♪ They ain't got nowhere to go,
where they was ♪
♪ Yeah, you know who took that
from you, come get it back in ♪
♪ Blrrrd, blrrrd,
come get it back in ♪
♪ We ain't mask up, no dodger,
rich know who it was ♪
♪ Extortin' just like the '80s,
get it in blood ♪
♪ Yeah, you know who took that
from you, come get it
♪ Back in blood ♪
-♪ Killed your mans, you keep on
talkin', better get that in ♪
♪ Gave my shawty and them a dub,
and they gon' walk inside the ♪
♪ Hit his lil'
with that switch ♪
♪ I bet that switch
switch up his ♪
♪ The opps, inside my city,
lil' bro put them in the ♪
♪ You can't come back
to your hood, huh? ♪
-♪ Nope ♪
-♪ He was dissin' on my cousin ♪
♪ Now his all in
that wood, huh? ♪
♪ Book his,
I wish he would come ♪
♪ V. Roy pop up out that cut
with that new Glock,
♪ I wish he would run ♪
♪ Your -- playin',
I'm really icy ♪
♪ Pooh Shiesty, that's my dawg ♪
♪ But, Pooh, you know
I'm really shiesty ♪
♪ You get all them O.T.
that you really ♪
♪ Tell the truth about
your gang, they really dyin' ♪
-♪ Blrrrd, blrrrd, I got ♪
-♪ My own fire,
don't need security ♪
-♪ In no club,
all that woofin' on the net ♪
-♪ I thought you was a thug ♪
-♪ They ain't got
nowhere to go ♪
-♪ We shot up
everywhere they was ♪
-♪ Yeah, you know
who took that from you ♪
♪ Come get it back in blood ♪
♪ Blrrrd ♪
-♪ Come get it back in blood ♪
-♪ We ain't mask up, no dodger,
rich know who it ♪
♪ Extortin' just like the '80s,
get it in blood ♪
♪ Yeah, you know
who took that from you ♪
♪ Come get it back in blood ♪
♪ Blrrrd, come get it
back in blood ♪
♪ Blrrrd ♪
-♪ Blrrrd ♪
-♪ Big blrrrd, blrrrd ♪
♪♪